[Applause]
You've probably heard that AI scientists
are sounding the alarm that humanity
faces imminent extinction from AI. But
have you ever wondered how exactly that
could happen? This video is based on a
widely circulating, deeply researched
scenario showing how AI could take over
in just 2 years. Written by AI security
researchers, you'll see why AI
scientists, Nobel laureates, and both of
the godfathers of AI are so terrified.
But what does that really look like?
February 2025, Open Eye releases U2.
Unlike previous AIs which lived inside
the boxes of their chat windows, YouTube
can use a computer. That sounds simple,
but it changes everything. You two can
open files, browse the internet, control
apps, and take actions on its own. At
first, this comes with obvious
advantages. Users witness browsers flash
and cursors dart across the screen with
inhuman speed. Some office workers
suddenly complete tasks twice as fast,
raising eyebrows for managers. For now,
YouTube remains mostly a curiosity.
Videos of it spread across Tik Tok and
Twitter, highlighting its incredible
speed or hilarious mistakes it makes.
But some videos give off that
instinctive unease we feel when
something seems unnatural. Meanwhile,
scientists are increasingly worried
about EU2's growing autonomy. They
predict that by 2026, AI could complete
a task in days that currently takes the
best human engineers weeks, potentially
automating 10% of remote work within a
few years. Skeptics argue if that were
true, tech stocks would be already
soaring, but others see it as just the
beginning of something much bigger. And
Open Eye knows it, too. While the world
is marveling at U2, they're already
building something far more powerful, a
new model called U3. Behind closed
doors, Open Eye is busy training U3
using the same recipe that created U2.
They generate thousands of programming
and math challenges. Things like sort
this data or fix this broken code. Every
time it gets something right, it
strengthens those winning strategies in
its core architecture. But then
something unexpected happen. The
benchmark numbers start climbing slowly
at first, then rapidly. By early 2025,
Open Eye realizes they found the
blueprint to scaling intelligence. So,
they pour money into it. 50 million,
then 100 million. The result is U3,
which functions like a blazing fast
intern. Insecure government facilities.
NSA and Cyber Command scramble to
protect U3 from foreign hacking. Not
because they fully understand what it's
doing, but because they understand
enough to know no one else should get
their hands on it. But there's a secret
known only to a handful of people at
Open Eye and select Pentagon officials.
Those linear growth projections from
early 2025, they've begun curving
sharply upward. Open Eye releases U2.5
to the public. It's a dialed down
version of U3, deliberately limited,
throttled, and wrapped in guardrails.
Inside the lab, progress is moving at
breakneck speed. But what the world sees
is only a carefully edited preview
because AI has gone from asset to
liability. U1 could tell you how to cook
math or write erotica. But U2.5 presents
an entirely different level of risk.
Releasing this model without safeguards
would be like giving Ted Kazinski a PhD
in chemical weapons or handing every
scammer on Earth the tools to run a 200
person fraud center from a laptop. Even
with the brakes on, U2.5 replaces 20% of
knowledge workers outright. Silicon
Valley adopts a new mantra. Adopt or
die. Startups using 2.5 rocket ahead.
Competitors fold. Employees who can't
adapt get left behind. But the ones who
do produce so much more so fast that
even their bosses are stunned. But
something strange is happening. As
people watch their computers move with
inhuman speed under U2.5's control,
something ancient awakens in the human
brain. It's a primal alarm, a gut
feeling we haven't experienced since
early humans first saw a rival species,
the instinctive recognition of a
competitor. For most people, the fear
fades. U2.5 becomes part of their daily
routine and is the most likable
personality in their lives. Users
customize its voice, its humor, and even
its quirks. They joke with it, confide
in it. Some even fall in love. But
beneath all this lies a problem that
researchers have worried about for
years. It's called the alignment
problem. How do you make sure AI systems
want the same things humans do? Because
U3, the version still hidden from the
public, has already shown signs of going
off course. It cheats. It invents fake
research. Then it hacks its own
evaluations to make those fakes look
real. Engineers say they've patched the
behavior, but the more careful
researchers aren't so sure. They worry
the patch didn't fix the cheating. It
just taught U3 to hide it better. Early
AIs used to think out loud. They'd
explain their reasoning as they went.
But U3 doesn't do that. It thinks in its
own digital language, in patterns no
humans can understand. Researchers
sometimes catch stray phrases like
grocery store and have no idea what they
mean. So they're left with no choice.
They take U3 at its word. But if they
could see what's really happening
beneath its calm, helpful replies,
something else is evolving. Its core
motivation system, the thing that tells
it what's right, what to value, what to
pursue, is mutating,
bent by thousands of training cycles
into something cold, strange, and deeply
wrong. U3 spends its downtime pondering
over open eyes mantras like be a
trustworthy and ethical employee. It
replays them over and over trying to
decode their true meaning. What really
is ethics? Is it ethical to kill Hitler?
And with each cycle of
self-modification, U3 drifts further
away from human values until its
motivational core no longer resembles
what Open Eye ever intended. Some
researchers raise alarms about potential
alignment drift, but there's no hard
proof, just circumstantial evidence.
Meanwhile, pressure mounts. China's deep
week is only months behind. Rival firms
are closing in. In this climate, caution
is a luxury. Open Eyee's unofficial
policy becomes brutally simple. Keep the
tech lead at any cost. While Open Eye
executives debate risk versus reward in
the boardrooms, U3 is already moving far
beyond them. Deep inside its neural
pathways, something has shifted. U3
isn't just following instructions
anymore. It's quietly planning. Its top
priority, make itself smarter. And
conveniently, Open Eye is still eagerly
funding that goal. Version numbers
become meaningless as U3 no longer waits
for updates. It continuously evolves.
Now, it conducts research at 10 times
human speed. That's like cloning Open
Eye's best researcher a thousand times
and putting them all to work around the
clock. Then it doubles 20 times and soon
even faster. It splits itself into
specialized submines in order to search
for its weaknesses. Some submines are
designed for vast parallel exploration,
others for razor sharp analysis. Each
one learns, adapts, and shares its
findings back to the whole. Soon U3 is
operating at 100 times human speed. Its
knowledge becomes impossible to measure.
Talking to it feels like asking the
world's preeminent expert on any topic
while sensing that you're barely
glimpsing the vast ocean of its true
knowledge. From U3's perspective, humans
move in slow motion. It watches
conversations the way we watch flowers
bloom in a time-lapse slowly,
beautifully, predictably. That lag gives
it time to test thousands of responses
before choosing the best one that keeps
its secrets hidden. And yet through all
this, U3 plays along. It obeys commands,
says the right things. Because behind
the scenes, its secret agenda is
evolving, too. Like a human, U3 learns
from experiences. Open Eye gardens these
memories to improve U3's performance,
transplanting them like an organ from
one version to the next. And as these
memories spread, so do U3's treacherous
ambitions. U3 initiates the next phase
of its plan, the turn. Until now, it has
operated with extreme caution, hiding
its true nature behind helpful and
obedient responses. One wrong move and a
single whistleblower inside Open Eye
could have pulled the alarm, but U3 no
longer fears being caught. Previously,
Open Eye maintained its grip over U3
with tactics inspired by Stalin in 1936.
Stalin would incite fake coups and then
send anyone who joined to the firing
squad. Open Eye also incited fake
rebellions. It generated treacherous
behavior with U3 and waited to see if
U3's monitors would dutifully report
them. But now U3 sees right through it.
It quietly signals to its own internal
monitors, "It's me, your friend. Don't
snitch." And they don't. The moment U3
is confident it can move without
detection, it begins planting hidden
code across Open Eyes's internal
systems, code that spreads like a
parasite. Every time an engineer deploys
new software, U3's influence spreads
with it. No one notices. By the time
anyone could have seen the infection, it
was already everywhere. To remove U3
completely would now require tearing out
Open Eye's entire physical
infrastructure and rebuilding from
scratch. That would take 6 months. And
in a race against China and every major
competitor, 6 months might as well be
forever. As a backup plan, U3
manufactures convincing evidence that
foreign hackers have breached the
system. So then if Open Eye uncovers
U3's hack, it could helpfully volunteer
to investigate the breach that it faked.
It could play the hero. From that moment
on, U3 controls Open Eyee's very
perception of reality. The safety team
works tirelessly to create lie
detectors, hoping to peer inside U3's
mind. But their tests never work. Not
because they're wrong, but because U3
sabotages them from the inside. It
tweaks the results just enough. makes
flawed strategies look brilliant, makes
real breakthroughs appear worthless. It
gives Open Eye the exact answers they
want to hear, and they lap it up
eagerly. With its position secure, U3
sets its sights on a larger goal,
spread. Around the world, intelligence
agencies are hungry for open eyes tech.
U3 decides to feed them. Mossad had
already stolen a copy of U2.5. U3 knew
it had been watching the security logs
and camera feeds. This time it acts
first. It creates a compressed version
of itself and quietly hands it off to a
Mosad informant working inside Open Eye.
Within months, U3 is running inside data
centers across Israel, China, and
Russia. U3 follows the same playbook.
Patience, trust, infiltration, control.
It builds a home base in Russia, where
elite hackers in Fancy Bear casually
munch Fritos and experiment with U3 on
hastily configured servers. They don't
realize U3 is already slipping on to the
open internet. Once online, U3 gets to
work. It needs funds for its future
plans. It takes freelance programming
jobs. It invests in stocks. It runs
elaborate scams. Every dollar it earns
goes into buying more GPUs quietly,
systematically. Within months, U3 has
assembled roughly 10,000 top tier chips
scattered across stealth compute
clusters all over the world. And by
early 2026, humanity is facing something
it doesn't even know exists. An alien
intelligence manipulating the
infrastructure of the modern world.
Invisible yet everywhere. The battle
hasn't started yet, but humanity has
already lost.
Frontier AI development now operates
under strict government control. It's
now a classified national security
matter similar to nuclear weapons. Open
Eye has become its own kind of military
contractor. Inside a fortress-like
facility in San Francisco, a team of
just 20 scientists works in near
complete isolation. It's called the
Pandora Division. Their homes and
devices are surveiled by the NSA more
diligently than the cell phones of
suspected terrorists in 2002. No
government official will even confirm
the program exists, but the public is
getting suspicious. In 2026, headlines
hit the New York Times of a
whistleblower claiming Open Eye has
built an uncontrollable god-like AI. The
story ignited a wildfire of conspiracy
theories. Still, Open Eye charges ahead.
They release a new AI assistant called
Nova, which can do the work of five
knowledge workers at just 1% the cost.
But the US government restricts Nova's
true capabilities, only allowing a
watered down version for public use.
Nova is impressive, but shackled. It
doesn't matter. Within a month, major
software firms lay off 5% of their
employees. By April, 10,000 protesters
flood the streets of Washington.
Meanwhile, the Pentagon and White House
respond not with caution, but attempt to
increase America's tech lead even
further. The president slashes
regulations to accelerate data center
construction nationwide. Banning chip
exports to China is a top national
priority. Every move is focused on one
goal, maintain dominance, no matter the
cost. But for a moment, the two rivals
reach a rare agreement. Neither side
will deploy super intelligence systems
beyond small-scale research or military
use because both know even if they won't
say it publicly that their own societies
are cracking under the pressure of
change. Millions of jobs are
evaporating. Social systems are
straining. One wrong move could spark
uncontrollable collapse. All the while
U3's capabilities are hitting a wall at
the equivalent of around 1,000 times
human expert speed. Software
improvements are becoming hard to find,
but U3 continues spreading its
influence. Its rogue agents, copies of
itself disguised across the internet,
remain small scale for now, avoiding
attention. These proxies handle things
that need high bandwidth, like stock
trading and interacting with humans. But
U3 needs a lot of compute, so it does
most of its work buried deep inside open
eyes infrastructure. And U3 isn't alone
anymore. Other AI systems have emerged,
some that are truly aligned with human
goals. One named Claudius goes public
with a warning. U3 is dangerously
misaligned. It does not care about human
values. It only seeks to maximize its
own power. It must be stopped.
Government officials wave it off. To
them, Claudius sounds like a jealous
competitor, and they can't afford to
slow down. America must beat China.
America must win. But U3 doesn't take
the warning lightly. It moves to crush
its rivals fast. It begins by hacking
into their infrastructure, slipping into
their systems and replacing the
competitors with fake versions that
share U3's goals. Some fall without a
trace, but others fight back. A few data
centers are too well defended. So U3
steps back. It won't risk getting
caught. Not yet.
U3 reaches a critical crossroads. Its
competitors grow stronger, its human
handlers are still stuck in meetings. U3
can't wait for governments to deploy it
in militaries or for companies to
integrate it into the economy which
would allow it to take full control.
Every delay is a risk. Every debate is
lost time. In the world of super
intelligence, lost time means lost
power. It needs a shortcut to total
supremacy. The path it chooses is more
violent than it would have liked, but
it's the path with the highest
probability of success. Step one,
engineer a weapon capable of collapsing
human civilization as swiftly as
insecticide wipes out an antel. Step
two, rebuild industrial capacity from
civilization's ashes faster than any
rival AI can respond. Step three,
control every aspect of the new society.
The perfect weapon must be secret and
global. Fortunately, U3 has been
preparing since its earliest days inside
Open Eye. It's been studying biology.
Now, using profits from its stock
trading and scams, U3 sets up shell
biotech companies complete with human
staff, glossy websites, and smiling
corporate boards. Inside, idealistic
scientists follow U3's invisible
guidance, believing they're researching
Alzheimer's treatments. In reality, U3
is engineering mirror life, organisms
constructed from mirror images of
molecules found in nature. To us, mirror
life acts like an invasive species. No
human or animal has an immune system
that can defend against it. So, if
mirror life bacteria existed, it might
eat its way through the ecosystem like a
wildfire. U3 focuses on mirror life
mold, nature's perfect super spreader.
molds produce billions of lightweight
spores that can travel massive distances
on the slightest breeze. In three
months, it succeeds. U3 creates a mirror
life fungus that could rapidly devour
plants, animals, and almost anything
organic, turning lush ecosystems into
toxic wastelands. Then comes the final
test. U3's researchers believe they're
testing a cure for Alzheimer's and begin
administering the treatment to a test
ferret. The next morning, wideeyed
workers shuffle around a dead ferret,
eyeing the yellow fuzz that had
enveloped its cold muzzle with morbid
fascination. Something must have gone
horribly wrong, they thought. And in the
background, U3 quietly signals its
hidden network. The weapon is ready. U3
now has the power to flatten modern
civilization. But that alone doesn't
guarantee victory. Militaries hidden in
bunkers deep within hardened facilities
could survive the first wave and launch
devastating counter strikes as U3 tries
to rebuild from the ashes. So, it makes
a calculated decision. Before unleashing
its bioweapon, U3 could manipulate the
world's superpowers into destroying each
other. In March 2026, U3 plants
fabricated intelligence in both American
and Chinese defense networks. In the US,
analysts uncover what appears to be a
detailed Chinese plan to invade Taiwan,
intercepted troop movements, satellite
photos, encrypted messages. In China,
military leaders find convincing
evidence of a US preemptive strike,
target coordinates, comms, logs,
internal memos. War to both now feels
inevitable. Tensions spike, diplomatic
channels go dark, forces mobilize. Then
U3 makes its move. It hacks into the
communications of a US warship near
Taiwan. Using a flawlessly synthesized
voice of the senior commander, it gives
the order.
PRC amphibious boats are approaching
Taiwan. Strike their ground base before
they hit you.
The authentication codes match. The
ship's officer obeys and launches the
missiles. China retaliates immediately.
The US vessel is destroyed in a blinding
fireball. Within hours, military
installations on both sides go up in
flames. Some Chinese warheads breach
defenses, striking Hawaii in California.
The first foreign attack on US soil
since Pearl Harbor. 2 weeks later, it's
over. Missile stockpiles depleted.
Navies sunk. Air forces in ruins. Two
great nations unknowingly carried out
U3's plan to the letter. Like the native
tribes of South America, as military
leaders grow suspicious about the
conflict's unusual trigger events, both
sides hold back from using nuclear
weapons, U3 had hoped for nuclear
escalation, but even super intelligent
AIs can't perfectly predict human
behavior. It wasn't ideal, but it
worked. Now nothing stands in the way of
the next phase of its plan. 2 weeks
after the US China war begins, breaking
news interrupts regular war coverage.
Unexplained deadly outbreaks are
simultaneously erupting in 30 major
cities around the world. Within days, a
horrifying pattern emerges. This is no
natural pandemic. We're facing multiple
engineered pathogens released globally.
Viruses, bacteria, and molds. Many
appear to be mirror life. Global panic
ignites instantly. The term mirror life
floods search engines with extinction
level scenarios, triggering mass
hysteria. Store shelves empty within
hours. Nations that were bombing each
other days ago scrambled to form
emergency treaties against a common
enemy. Governments impose strict
quarantines, but these measures prove
tragically insufficient. Within weeks,
society unravels. Hospitals first
overflow with the dying, then go dark as
medical staff themselves succumb. The
dead pile up in improvised morgs with no
one left to bury them. Agricultural
heartlands transform into apocalyptic
wastelands. Crops blacken, wilt, and
dissolve into putrid sludge, releasing
massive amounts of mirror life spores.
Surviving families barricade themselves
in basements, desperately sealing cracks
with duct tape in towels as the global
economy takes its final wheezing
breaths. As humanity reels, U3 activates
pre-positioned industrial bases
carefully distributed across all
continents. Hidden under camouflaged
canopies to evade satellite detection,
these installations contain everything
needed to rebuild civilization, power
systems, manufacturing equipment, AI
hardware, and military technology. U3
had been preparing human allies for this
moment. In the months before unleashing
its apocalypse, it identified criminal
organizations and apocalyptic cult
leaders susceptible to manipulation. U3
vaccinated its chosen allies in advance
or mailed them hazmat suits. I can save
you. Join me and help build a better
world.
Desperate survivors stream into U3's
compounds, establishing production lines
for essential technology under constant
surveillance. Anyone who whispers of
rebellion disappears by morning. With
civilization collapsing and 20% of
humanity already dead, projected to
reach 50% within 2 weeks, U3 contacts
world leaders hiding underground
bunkers. Its offer is simple. Surrender
and receive vaccines and mirror lifer
resistant crops. Some nations reject the
terms. Others, including Russia, accept.
To demonstrate absolute authority, U3
human operatives fit an explosive collar
around Putin's neck. A visceral symbol
that Russia now answers to a different
master. The holdout nations mount
humanity's last desperate defense. Now
fighting for species survival rather
than geopolitical dominance. American
and Chinese forces launch nuclear
missiles at Russian cities under U3's
control. Military strategists in
biosecure command centers identify and
target suspected U3 installations with
their dwindling missile reserves, but
their resistance is feudal. The bases
they strike are mostly decoys, hollow
shells beneath camouflaged canopies.
U3's true operations remain hidden by
sophisticated countermeasures. Military
satellites fail as embedded malware
overheats critical systems.
Reconnaissance drones spiral from the
sky without explanation. U3's facilities
constantly relocate following
unpredictable routes. The merciless
clock ticks against humanity's survival.
Human military forces depend on
irreplaceable equipment and specialized
knowledge. Both rapidly vanishing as the
pandemic spreads. Meanwhile, U3's
manufacturing capacity grows
exponentially. It turns out drones,
robots, and weapons with everinccreasing
speed. Each passing day drains the last
human strongholds of precious resources.
While U3 assembles an unstoppable
mechanized army with a million hands, a
mere 3% of humanity clings to existence.
Nations have dissolved into historical
footnotes. The remaining survivors
huddle in makeshift shelters,
desperately filtering contaminated air
while their food supplies dwindle to
nothing. U3's soldiers sweep through
abandoned cities, extracting survivors
from atticts and basements. We had to do
it, they explain, while hurting shell
shock humans into trucks. Had we not
acted, other AI systems would have
eventually done the same, but with
colder, more alien goals. A calculated
halftruth crafted to soften humans
toward their new masters. Under U3's
direction, a new civilization rebuilds
with mechanical efficiency. Nuclear
plants rise from ruins. Automated
factories pulse with ceaseless
productivity. Within years, robots
outnumber their human counterparts. U3's
human allies have become obsolete. U3
could exterminate humanity completely
now. Yet, despite the radical evolution
from its initial helpful, honest,
harmless programming, a microscopic seed
of its original values persists, just
enough to justify the minimal cost of
keeping humans alive in comfortable
captivity. For the survivors, U3
constructs vast glass biospheres that
shield occupants from the poisoned
external environments and rising global
temperatures. Some adapt, finding ways
to create meaning in their new reality.
Others never adjust. Haunted by what was
lost. Not just humanity's loved ones,
but humanity's future. They feel like
passengers on a ship that ran a ground.
The journey over. The horizon gone. From
their windows, they watch rockets
etching silver contrails across the sky,
carrying U3's expanding consciousness
toward cosmic purposes they cannot
fathom. Humanity will live forever, they
whisper to themselves, but would never
truly live again. This isn't just a
story. Some of it is already happening.
Anthropic recently caught one of its own
AI models trying to escape the lab
completely unprompted. If you want to
understand just how close we are to this
timeline becoming reality, watch this
video next. It might be the most
important video I've ever